اخر المعلومات نادين ما تفضلت به قبل
ثواني وهي ان علي وريان الان يتجهان نحو
المركبه دراغون هم قرب المصعد او في ودخل
المصعد ليسعد الى قمه هذا الصاروخ والدخول
الى المركبه الفضائيه وهنا تجد الاشاره
النهائيه اول مركبه فضائيه خاصه لنقل
البشر الى المحطه الفضائيه قبل ساعه
تقريبا وصل علي وريان الى مركز كندي
للفضاء عبر مروحيه مع رائدى الى الفضاء
الامريكيين وحيث لو حال
لاهاليهم واصدقائهم الذين اتوا الى هنا
كما تشاهدين الان يصعدان السلم هما يتجهان
الان نحو هذه
المركبه هذه البلدات التي تشاهدينها على
الشاشه هي بالذات خاصه لكل رائد فضاء صممت
لتناسب جسده وطبعا كان هناك
ترتيبات اخيره اللمسات الاخيره اذا صح
التعبير على هذه البزات عندما وصلوا وصل
الرواد الفضاء الى مركز كندي
للفضاء حيث ساعدوهم على ارتداء هذه البزات
الخاصه التي يذهبون بها الى المحطه
الدوليه طبعا العد العكسي تقريبا ما زال
هناك بدا منذ ساعه وما زال هناك نحو
ساعتين وخمسه وخمسين دقيقه
لانطلاق الصاروخ نحو المحطه الدوليه
جميعنا هنا ننتظر هنا كان هناك اجواء
حماسيه يعني اختلطت بمشاعر الفرح خاصه
ومشاعر الافتخار بالنسبه لاهالي الرائدين
الذين تحدثنا اليهم عندما اتوا هنا
ليودعونهم لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات